While I was doing my tiny
little bit of analysis
to figure out whether the basic
or the trial plan made sense,
and we did this whole
analysis of saying well,
at what number of sessions
does the trial plan
give me the same cost
as the basic plan?
And I did this whole
calculation and said
it was at five sessions.
I didn't realize it, but the guy
at the front desk of the yoga
studio was watching
me the whole time.
And then all of a
sudden he said, "Well,
that's all cute
what you did Sal.
I understand what you said."
There's some number
of sessions where
12s is equal to
20 plus 8s, where
we get the same exact cost.
And so you said 20 plus
8x is equal to 12 plus s.
Or another way you could say it
is the C that 20 plus 8s gets
is going to be the same
as the C that 12s gets.
So we just equate them
and then you solved for s.
And then you solved
for the cost.
But the guy says, "I have
different way of doing it,
and I'm curious to see if I'm
going to get the same answer."
So here's a way of
thinking about it.
He says, well look.
Look at this right here.
We know from our basic plan
that the total monthly cost
is actually going to be $20
upfront fee plus $8 per session
times the number of sessions.
So we know that.
And the whole thing we
wanted to think about
is at what number of sessions
do we get the same cost for both
the basic and the trial plan?
So he says, I have an idea.
I have an idea of turning this
into an equation of only one
unknown.
Right now it's an
equation of two unknowns.
I have a certain cost that's
dependent on a certain number
of sessions.
He thinks he's got a way of
getting rid of the C. He says,
what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just subtract
a C from the left-hand side.
And then I quickly point to
him, I was like, look look.
You can't just do one thing
to one side of an equation.
Then the equality
won't be true anymore.
And he's like, oh
no, no, don't worry.
I'm going to do the same
thing on the other side
of the equation.
And so I tell him,
well, what good
would that be, subtracting
C from both sides?
Because then you're
going to end up
with a C on the right-hand side.
You're going to end up
with 20 plus 8s minus C. So
you're not going to
get rid of the C,
you're still going
to have two unknowns.
He's like, no, no, no Sal.
You don't get it.
I'm going to subtract C
from the left-hand side,
but I know that we're
looking for an s where
12s is going to give us
the same as whatever C is.
Whether I use the basic plan or
whether I use the trial plan,
I'm going to get the same cost.
So I'll subtract
the cost, whatever
that cost is, that same
cost that either the basic
or the trial plan will
give me, I'll subtract that
from the left-hand side, because
that'll cancel out with that.
But from the right-hand
side, I'll just subtract 12s.
So he says, I'm just
going to subtract C
from the left-hand
side and I'm going
to subtract 12s from
the right-hand side.
So I'm wondering, is
this a valid thing to do?
He's essentially
subtracting this equation
from that equation.
He's subtracting the C
from the left-hand side
and he's subtracting this
12s from the right-hand side.
Does that make any sense?
Well, let's just think about it.
We know that if we have an
equation, if we add or subtract
one thing to one side, we
have to do the same thing
to the right-hand side.
What he's doing,
he's saying, look.
For either plan we use,
we know that there's
some number of
sessions where we're
going to get the same cost.
So let's subtract that same
cost from the left-hand side.
And that's going to be
the same thing as 12s.
We know that this
has to be true.
We know that both
of these statements
have to be true at
this point of equality.
So he says, look.
If these two things are equal
to each other, subtracting a 12s
is completely equivalent
to subtracting a C.
So this actually is
a valid operation.
He is subtracting
the same thing.
He's subtracting a
C over here and he's
subtracting a 12s over here.
We know they're the same
thing, because we're
putting that constraint on us.
We know that both C has
to be equal to 20 plus 8s
and C has to be equal to 12s.
Because C has to
be equal to 12s,
we can subtract C from one
side and 12s from the other.
But let's see if this
actually gets us anywhere.
So if we subtract C from one
side and 12s from the other,
what do we actually get?
Well, let's think it through.
On the left-hand side,
if I have C minus C, well
I just end up with 0.
They just completely
negate each other,
and there's nothing left
here on the left-hand side.
So I just have 0 on
the left-hand side.
On the right-hand side,
I have the 20 still.
And then I have 8 of
something, and then I'm
subtracting 12 of something.
So 8s's minus 12s's is going
to give me negative 4s's.
So that's going to
give me negative 4s's.
So this is interesting now.
I now have one equation
and one unknown.
That one unknown is s.
And so I should be able
to solve for that s.
But how can I do it?
Well, I always like
to isolate my variable
on one side of the equation.
And so now, I'll isolate
it on the left-hand side.
And as you know, there's
many, many ways of doing this.
And so, what can I do
if I want to get the s's
on the left-hand side
and get rid of them
on the right-hand side?
Well, if I want to get rid of
them on the right-hand side,
I'm subtracting 4s's here.
I just have to add 4s's.
But once again, I can't just
do that to the right-hand side.
Then the equality
won't be true anymore.
I have to also do that
to the left-hand side.
And so what will that give me?
Well, we get 0 plus 4s
on the left-hand side,
which gives us just 4s.
And that's going to be equal
to-- On the right-hand side,
negative 4s and 4s,
they negate each other.
We're left with just 20.
So we're left with
4s is equal to 20.
To solve for s, we
just divide by 4.
We have 4 times something.
The special number of
sessions is equal to 20.
Well, 4 times
something divided by 4
is just going to
be that something.
But we can't just divide
the left side by 4.
We also have to divide
the right-hand side by 4.
So we're left with s is
equal to 20 divided by 4,
or s is equal to 5
sessions, which is exactly
the answer we got before.
And then we can go back
into either of the plans
and see that the cost
will still be $60.
And so what's neat here
is that both myself
and the guy at the front
desk of the yoga studio,
we had very, very
different approaches
to solving this problem.
But because what each of us
did was logically correct--
and this is what's really
neat about algebra--
we got to the same conclusion.
As long as we do
logically correct things,
we will always get
to the same answer.